in a bid for more diversity a u.s
theater scrapped production as
cinderella because the cast was too
white
we believe unapologetically in the
changes we are making
and we believe that all of our
kind-hearted guests will follow us on
this journey
the artistic director of the minnesota
production says the cast was
98 white breaking its diversity policies
then
but eyebrows have been raised as the
companies based in a suburb that's
overwhelmingly white
making it hard to fill racial quotas
it's ignited a firestorm
on social media
i will scrap my plans to ever visit
chanhassen dinner theater
declaring the diversity card at a local
dinner theater is simply bad business
and unnecessary
no problem one more venue to never get
my money
ever again julia rivera with reactionary
times online news site says the
theater's decision reflects a dangerous
development
this whole cancel culture sort of um you
know a super diversity
mafia that's that's operating right now
is basically what they're doing to me
when i look at something like this from
afar is that they're trying to
legitimize
anti-white racism i mean we're not
talking about the public sector this is
not
you know let's say a government entity
that hired only
white employees this is you know
subjective issue this is
art let's say there was a play that
somehow was casted
let's say that they're in a a black
neighborhood or the story takes place
you know within black characters are we
gonna force
them to cast white actors
to playing black people it just it
doesn't none of this really
makes any sense other than the fact that
they're one trying to call
attention and and create controversy
maybe to bring attention to their
theater
who knows and two it's an another
attempt to me again to
legitimize this anti-white racism that
we continue to see
in plain sight in america and other
places
you